i mean we're talking about the tape
brothers right and the paul brothers
arguably the two most famous set of
brothers in the world right
but
you've got two sons
right well similar age difference
between these guys for me here's what i
like yeah i'm a pro competition guy
right the fact that he went on rumble
and he got a half a million subs in two
weeks you know who wins you know who
wins the market the world
the fact that he went on rumble got a
half a million subs good job for chris
for making that move by the way we know
and we've had good conversations at the
house with him and he's making a move
right now on uh uh our bodies we got we
like russell brandon and a few other
guys
but the stop he's he sees you on the
right rumble yeah
amazing about it amazing but go back to
this i want both to be competing
completely i got two boys i want the
tates going against paul's to go against
this completely i run an insurance
company we have a lot of siblings that
compete against each other it's great
for the market but where i was going i
said who is logan paul's
playbook he's following right he's 27.
the video you talked about 23 when it
was in december in 2017 i want to say
when he was in japan the video with him
and his girl when you know the the what
do you call it uh
that when he got you got kicked off of
big brother whatever it was in 2016 but
that video was from 2012 10 years ago
he's 25 so
23 25 you know you're coming from that
kind of an environment you can kind of
hold the two things at the same level of
accountability one is suicide the other
one is
you know a extreme method of sexual you
know consensual consensual sex that you
know it is what it is but this is where
i was going with it
years ago
and i'm just trying to see because you
know the whole thing what would jesus do
everybody has a ww
something you do right yeah so logan
when he did the japan thing the story
came out he was talking about it openly
that the rock said rocks people said hey
man you got to distance yourself from
him but apparently what he told is
rocks people contacted to say hey delete
all the pictures that we have together
etc etc so maybe
he's going into wrestling he's following
rock's footsteps
rock is definitely somebody that if he
ever wanted to run for office that's a
guy that could do it if he wanted it i
think logan's another guy whether you
like him or not i think he's the he's
got the pedigree to one day run it
doesn't mean you're going to support his
policies correct but he is a guy that's
going in the direction of one day
running 20 30 years he could do it so
maybe he's sitting there saying
what would the rock do
uh he distanced himself from me well
maybe i got to stop defending this guy
and i got to distance myself from him i
wasn't going on the angle of you know
hillary clinton called or all these guys
no i was going more what playbook is he
following i understand exactly what
you're saying but i would i would
disagree and the reason i would disagree
is because that would
that that requires a degree of thought
and intellect that logan paul doesn't
opposites
no i know he's an idiot he's not
thinking that far ahead he's literally
someone has told him say this and he
says
it doesn't matter it's not just me
there's been loads of examples and i put
on my my podcast on rumble where we went
through all the times where something
came up some controversial subject that
people were discussing discussing is
this good for the public consciousness
the answer was always basically no is
this necessary for children to be
consuming the answer was always
basically no but it was purported by the
hollywood elites and logan was always
the number one person sticking up for it
he is bought and sold by somebody
whether his management team whoever they
are they think it's good for him to act
this particular way he does not think
for himself he says what he's told to
say but isn't that hollywood in general
completely right the matrix exactly the
matrix so we agree the matrix the agents
of the matrix some minds are not ready
to be freed and those who are not ready
to be freed are going to sit there and
they're going to defend the system what
does morpheus say himself he's sitting
there defending the system logan paul is
going to sit and pretend that the world
is going to be a better place if you
remove all opposing ideas and he's going
to sit there and say that because he's a
[ __ ] anyone with a brain understands if
you care about your children and your
children's children they need to live in
a world full of healthy competition
exactly as you said as soon as you
remove all
opposing viewpoints or all competition
you end in tyranny and anyone with a
brain will sit and say i don't if he had
any kind of character he'd say i
completely do not agree with what tate
says however d platforming is wrong
because of x he doesn't have to talk
about me or what i've said you can sit
there and say no do platforming is wrong
because we need to have opposing
viewpoints opposing ideals
idea a idea b the truth is perhaps in
the middle he has no intellect disagree
with somebody he can't do that he's not
smart enough yeah tate's bad today okay
tell me when he's good again he's a soul
individual when my hero arc completes
because we're at a transition stage when
my hero art completes and much like
batman people understand that we thought
he was the bad guy but we realized we
needed him and when i come back to save
gotham and the hero art completes you'll
see him and his little boyfriend back on
instagram saying hey it's funny and swap
again because it's allowed that's all he
is that's your prediction for him not
prediction is absolute matter of fact
especially it also couples in with the
fact that he's extremely jealous of my
brother and i success because my brother
and i success is not based on the same
successes that he enjoyed his success is
based on being a clown that's why he has
viewers he puts on a pokemon suit and he
jumps around like a clown he doesn't sit
there and give ideas or say things that
make people think to the point where
they genuinely resonate with your
mindset he's not intelligent enough of
that he's a performing clown as opposed
to a philosopher so they're different
opposite things and he knows that and it
upsets him he can't sit in front of a
camera by himself and say words that are
going to inspire the crowds of any city
in the world to shout to shout your name
if i were to walk through madrid right
now there would be young people shouting
my name top g top g that's because of
what i say
he puts on a pokemon suit and does a
dance he's an entertainer he's not a
thinker
just have that conversation yesterday
they're different
right and and this is sort of to your
credit we were having this conversation
because we knew we'd have this sort of
dialogue and he said
pat was asking me adam what do you think
i said you can understand something
about where my perspective on tate
is 95 of what i've seen about tate
is camera to the face him talking and
spitting game right when you're talking
about the paul brothers it's fighting
dancing red you know all sorts of
whatever whatever whatever i've never
seen you in the in the ring i've seen
your
uh
accolades highlights but i've never seen
that
so
people know your rhetoric they know what
you're saying
and whether they agree or disagree
you're known for what's coming out of
your mouth versus they're known for
antics and that's the difference between
a fan
and a viewer that's what it goes back to
goes back to initial point he has
viewers because he's a clown clowns can
have viewers that's fine and you need an
algorithm and you need a platform for
that but if you have genuine fans like i
do they ban me people are like to this
day where is tate and they will go
anywhere i am anywhere i am they will
come because they don't believe they can
find my rhetoric or my ideas somewhere
else if you ban logan paul they can find
another [ __ ] to jump around in front of
a camera for you they can promote
someone else inside of their algo and
steal his entire audience inside of a
weak he can disappear and they can
replace him he knows that that's why he
says what he's supposed to say if i stop
being the performing clown the new
performing clown comes the algo favors
him they put him up there and he does a
stupid dance and he gets all my viewers
i'm a completely different color fish
different story if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as kiyosaki tate connolly
parliamentary myself and others download
the app minect where you get a chance to
connect with these folks by the minute
you get to buy the minute or have face
times with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you may want to have download
the app connect and start connecting
with influencers and experts today
you